with just days to go before the major
the esports integrity commission issued
charges against three more players in
connection with the coach spectating bug
the decision's timing means that there
are three teams attending the antwerp
major without a coach and with the
community split on the timing of this
decision as well as a report to come
which e6 says will issue even more bans
it seems like we can't get away from
csgo's coaching bug let's dive in
[Music]
hey guys we're back at it again with
another video about competitive
integrity if that's something that you
enjoy seeing on donate me maybe like the
video subscribe to the channel and ring
the notification bell we like keeping on
top of this stuff but we'd like to know
how you feel about it too so
support the video cheers so if you
haven't been following this story i'm
happy to get you up to speed quickly in
2020 esic issued a ruling against three
coaches including heroic's hunden and
later expanded that to a total of 37
dance these suspensions were all for a
bug where a coach could essentially set
up a static point of view somewhere on
the map of their choosing once they were
locked in there and the game had started
they couldn't move but they could freely
rotate the camera it had to be set up
intentionally and the demo does actually
record the coach's point of view so by
reviewing the demo we can see precisely
what the coach saw now there's still the
question of whether this info was
actually given to the players on the
team by that coach and that's much
harder to determine but in e6 view it
doesn't matter too much whether the
players knew for sure because this
clearly had the potential to damage
competitive integrity if you want to go
deeper on this issue we did a couple of
donate me episodes already about them
including the initial scandal and how
things wrapped up at heroic so check
those out if you want to go a bit deeper
the investigation was never finalized
and it's dragged on for a while there
are a couple reasons for that the first
is that as the investigation proceeded
and it was a pretty big investigation
all told more bugs were discovered we
talked about the static view but there's
also others like one that lets you
literally fly around the map like you
have no clip enabled and then another
where you're sort of locked to a third
person view another issue is that esic
frankly isn't loaded down with resources
they had to review nearly 100 000 demos
for this investigation and that's about
15 terabytes of data from what they've
said it's a lot okay so in august 2021
nearly a year after that initial
statement from esic they said that more
cases had surfaced but also that
punishments were a little difficult to
figure out since a lot of the cases
flagged were very short durations of bug
use sometimes just seconds now before
you respond with a witty retort i want
to lay out the situation in some of
these cases there was a bug that a coach
got for a round or less and they will
say at least that they didn't
communicate that information to their
team so what is an appropriate
punishment for that scenario what should
esic do sure they should have reported
it we all agree that was the correct
thing to do but having the bug for a
round or less
can you punish that in the same way as
this this clip is from e6 investigation
and features then heroic coach
peacemaker flying around the map scoping
out the cts peacemaker is now the coach
for imperial but he was one of three
coaches punished in e6 may 5th
announcement before the antwerp major
the other two were halley of team spirit
and zach of 9z team all three of these
teams are now competing at the antwerp
major without their coach because of the
timing of this announcement but how did
we get to this point well reports in
recent weeks from several media outlets
including decerto and dust2 claimed that
not only had the investigation ballooned
in size but also that some coaches who
had qualified for antwerp were in e6
sites in some way this matter had to be
dealt with before the major so
peacemaker hallie and zach were
suspended provisionally and that may 5th
announcement says there's more to come
they also say that there's a fourth
coach at the major that is also involved
in the investigation but that their
offenses are nowhere near as serious as
the three who were suspended
provisionally so that brings us back to
punishment now e6 view is that it
doesn't have to prove that the coach
gave the info to the players because
they're exploiting a bug that has the
potential to affect competitive
integrity that in itself is an offense
it doesn't have to prove that players
knew that the coach was using the bug
now e6 may 5th announcement says that
the investigation is being finalized and
also that more punishments are
forthcoming soon they also break down
the bugs clearly into three separate
categories firstly there's the original
spectator bug which they call the static
spectator bug which allows a coach to
set up a single pov somewhere on the map
where they can then rotate the camera so
these cases are being handled using the
initial punishment guidelines that esic
announced alongside the investigation
with things like confessions cooperation
and whatnot earning some reduced
sentences secondly we have the free roam
bug now if you remember that peacemaker
clip we just showed that's an example of
that you can essentially fly around the
map fly through surfaces
follow players instead of having a fixed
pov this is clearly more damaging to
competitive integrity than a static pov
and e6 says it's going to be punished
accordingly e6 says three people
exploited this free roam buck but i want
to be very clear it's not all three of
the coaches who are suspended
provisionally from the major just
peacemaker who is accused of using the
free roam bug the other two are accused
of using the static bug the last one is
called the third person bug according to
esic this bug affected 47 participants
across 97 incidents and quote appeared
to be triggered by a server software
issue on two particular cs go tournament
platforms the third person spectator bug
allowed the affected participant to
observe the game from a locked
third-person view of the team's players
the affected participant was able to
cycle between players altering their
viewpoint accordingly further the
affected participant was able to
manipulate their viewport around the
player's access in a 360 degree range of
motion the bug appeared to resolve
itself at the end of a round and in many
cases coaches simply disconnected
reconnected which resolved the issue
having said that this means that this
bug affected participants for typically
one round or less it affected more
participants than the free roam bug but
was substantially less common than the
static spectator bug which of course had
to be set up intentionally now e6 view
isn't that this bug should be ignored
far from it their official guidance is
that a coach that was experiencing the
bugs should have flagged it admin then
disconnected and reconnected to the
server
under the guidance of an admin it's not
clear exactly how many coaches actually
did this so if you wrote it out to the
end of the round just to see what would
happen
you're facing punishment e6 says that if
you disconnected and thus played less
than a full round under the bug
they are gonna have to handle that on a
case-by-case basis in addition to
clearly setting the competitive
standards for counter-strike in the
future
it's also pretty clear that if coaches
had actually reported this it probably
could have been handled far quicker than
it was cheating might have been
prevented the investigation might have
been shortened so for every round that a
coach played under this bug they're now
facing a 30-day suspension instead of
the guidelines that were used for the
static bug all in all we're talking 84
participants who used the static pov bug
three who used the free roam and 47 who
used the third person bug but we'll need
to wait
likely until after the major to get the
full list of participants who are facing
punishment from esic still e6 seems
confident that recent investigatory
partnerships will allow them to ramp up
the speed of their investigation okay so
that wraps up e6 point of view how the
investigation expanded and how we can
expect it to likely end
but how is the community feeling about
this decision well the timing of e6
announcement means that if you're a team
that has one of these affected coaches
it's already too late to find another
coach or even a substitute if your coach
was your team's designated substitute
for some this raised the question of
whether teams had been intentionally
punished for their coach's prior use of
the bug the punishment might make sense
at first but think about it if the coach
was on an entirely different team from
their current roster and their current
roster couldn't have benefited from it
should that roster face punishment as
well or should the team be able to field
some kind of coach satirical cs go
accounts even joked about how the
torrent of clown emojis the bands
unleashed was pretty unlikely to reverse
the punishments and while i definitely
agree that any coach who exploited any
of these bugs should face punishment
immediately as quickly as possible
preferably
i do sympathize with fans who say listen
this coach might have done that back
when they weren't even a part of our
team but how is that our fault why can't
we even have a replacement coach now
some coaches have already heard their
names whispered in connection to this
investigation and they decided to review
their own demos one such coach was a mix
who when coaching for rogue appeared to
experience the bug but at least
according to him with a locked pov mix
framed it as having 15 seconds to react
to a bug he hadn't seen before or since
personally i think it's funnier to
imagine him slamming back some chipotle
without looking at his monitor or
something but obviously i don't know
what happened lastly allow me to soapbox
for a moment and listen i'll even break
the rules the show is called don't at me
but if you want to at me let's go this
has been one of the darkest most
humiliating moments for not just
counter-strike but esports as a whole
trust has been destroyed whether that's
between coaches and players teams and
fans or just the idea that what we're
watching is the thing that we all want
to watch through inhuman reactions
through forethought and planning through
guile and intuition
one team is better than the other it's
not impossible to rebuild that trust but
it's high time that both coaches and
players realize that this is more than
just a day job they are high profile
professionals their actions affect not
just their own livelihoods but those of
their colleagues those of their entire
esport and frankly the esports industry
as a whole if you want us to believe
that you care about esports beyond its
potential to make your bank account
balance go up please do better
don't make me get out the starcraft
history book
only some people will get how ominous
that ending is but yeah the starcraft
book is very large and extremely
shameful it's like when you just you
pick up the book you open it and then
you just slowly close it and you just
reshelve it and you just hope that
history never repeats itself that's
that's my view on the starcraft